what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and the newest trailer for marvel's what
if series has dropped harder than i was
as a baby giving us mcu lovers a new
look into one of the most
interesting mcu projects that i have
been waiting to see for the longest time
like i've been wanting
marvel to make this show for forever but
now if you think that marvel's what if
is just going to be another
marvel tv show like the ones that they
show hanging out with phineas and ferb
on the disney man channel
uh what if i told you that you were
deadass
wrong what if is a marvel studios
project meaning that the things that
jeffrey wright's watcher will show us
during the show
are actual canonical events that have
actually happened within the mcu
multiverse
and that these crazy flip-flop events in
the show will most likely tie into the
plot
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness coming up like hardcore so this
show is just
as significant as your one divisions or
your loki's so that all being the case
let us all hop
into the multiverse madness that is this
new trailer my nerd babies
yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a
job with peace
do we know each other and right off the
bat this trailer starts us off the same
way the entire marvel cinematic universe
started with the moment
this military convoy carrying tony stark
is attacked
by terrorism but more specifically this
trailer opens the exact way iron man 1
does with this wide shot of tony's
military escort being recreated
in animated form actually a lot of these
shots from this part of the trailer were
framed
exactly the way they happened in the
movie which serves as a really nice
contrast for when tony stark is rescued
by would-be king of wakanda
eric kimonger himself so you know he can
go home
and see peppa rather than stand here and
be peppered by shrapnel so if we out
here using loki terms killmonger
chucking that bomb was the nexus event
that caused this timeline to branch into
a what if killmonger saved tony's from
the ten rings timeline that i'm so hyped
to see because
these two men mega dead in our timeline
so it's really good to see them again
because good god have i missed them
anyways
moving on time
reality reality
it's changeable
and next up we see that seal of quality
that is the marvel studios logo that is
of course a staple of every marvel
trailer but
behind this logo this time around we can
see the watcher with his eyes
glowing in our direction sort of
suggesting that he could be watching
even our reality as well
as we watch the various realities of the
show which is a major fourth wall
breaking concept that i really hope that
they explore in this show
but more importantly we have a voiceover
of tilda swinton's the ancient one
stating how time in reality are
changeable before the trailer
symbolically demonstrates this by
undercutting footage of an animated
version of the iconic avengers one team
camera pan with a new team that seems to
be the avengers of the multiverse a team
composed
of t'challa as star lord a gamora decked
out in that new
thanos collection from nike a version of
black panther that could be killmonger
i'm not really sure there
as well as a version of thor that recent
merchandise leaks have revealed to be a
character called
party thor now i know what you're
thinking mt didn't we already see
a party thor and m game like you know he
was just drinking and having fun just
with his friends
no that was depressed xbox live party
thor
regular party thor is believed to be a
four from a timeline when thor goes to
midgard but doesn't exactly learn the
lessons in responsibility that he learns
in thor one it's a big difference there
party thor's what my friends did in
college and depressed
xbox live party thor is what i did in
college a real loser but that moment in
the trailer happens
after we see doctor strange use the time
stone to presumably send him back in
time to his pre-accident days
and is surrounded by these interesting
looking runes that sort of look like the
runes that we see in wanda
which is really interesting to me and
could actually end up tying into dr
strange too
moving on where you want to be
that's the question didn't it every
universe
is different then the trailer continues
with the shot of t'chall lord
flying over the collector's episode of
hoarders then cutting to t'challa
entering the power stone temple room of
morag instead of peter quill like we get
in guardians of the galaxy and then we
get the shot of yondu mentoring t'challa
implying that yanu's relationship with
t'challa as he grew up was
vastly different than that of peter
quill's upbringing with yondu like these
two
actually seem like an actual in-sync
space pirate duo
with them even working together later on
this trailer to beat tanelier's ass
sorry buddy should have collected
coupons instead [ __ ] and then we have
what appears to be bruce banner changing
to the hulk in front of a black widow
dressed like she's undercover at a
government facility or something which
is really intriguing because it seems
that these two are at odds here
considering that bruce is changing into
the hulk seemingly as a result to her
presence so maybe this is a universe
where black widow never joined shield
and she's trying to steal the secrets of
a super soldier program from general
ross and then we can see hulk and party
thor fighting a bunch of ultron bots
seemingly in two separate locations with
party thor seemingly fighting his bots
in the city of sin
of las vegas which is a stark contrast
to the holy city of asgard
suggesting that many of party thor's
asgardian-themed ragers may have taken
place here and chris angel probably
showed up
and blew a thor's mind with this dark
wizardry get the [ __ ] out of my house
now picture this you're all set to watch
the loki finale in your computer right
the pizza is hot the beverages are cool
but then you start up your macbook and
it's so slow by the time the title
sequence hits the pizza is cold and the
beverages are warm which is
unacceptable to speed up your mac use
today's sponsor clean my mac
x it's an all-in-one cleaning and
optimizing software for your mac
cleanmymacx helps to declutter your mac
by finding and offering to delete cash
logs and old mail attachments scattered
throughout your mac system
saving you gigabytes of space clean my
mac x was introduced 12 years ago and
has become a daily solution
for millions of users the app's most
popular feature is the smart scan which
examines for a system log files and user
cache that is no longer needed does a
quick malware check
and run some optimization tasks to speed
up your map and all this happens in just
a couple of seconds
clean my mac x also features powerful
protection module with malware removal
you can scan your macbook for
cryptocurrency miners viruses and adware
and remove them
instantaneously and the privacy feature
lets you control application permissions
and see which apps can access your
camera and microphone it also lets you
remove your chat history data from apps
like skype and other messengers
check out the app's full features for
free and find out how it can help you
and click the link in this video's
description to download clean my mac x
for free but anyways we also get this
glimpse of loki facing off against nick
fury and shield
with the full complement of the
asgardian army at his side
ready to mother freaking roll son which
makes you think that because thor never
learned how to be responsible on earth
in this timeline
loki was easily able to take over asgard
during those events of thor 1 as we can
see later on this trailer him using
the casket of ancient winners to freeze
a bunch of people slow down a little bit
there's a few people in the room that
don't understand
not me i i get it
who are you the name's captain carter
and then we are formally introduced to
captain carter a version of peggy carter
who got that good good irks kind [ __ ]
and none of that walmart nonsense that
peggy's grandniece was paddling on
magibor you know what i'm saying but in
particular this shot of her landing with
a sword is super interesting to me
because it looks like she just sliced
off the tentacles of one of these weird
squid-like creatures from later on in
the trailer that very much resembled the
obelisk from guardians of the galaxy vol
2. and i have a really good feeling that
these squid-like creatures are the many
angled ones of the marvel multiverse and
will probably be linked to that big old
tentacled eyeball that is schuma gorath
who was rumored for multiverse of
madness but anyways yeah we see captain
carter have a run in with a dark version
of dr strange who seems to have lost his
way
because when this version of doctor
strange shoots out those dang evil
wizard brains from his hands next to a
woman that i'm assuming is
christine palmer you can see some dark
particles whizzing around his phalanges
his magical phalanges maybe these dark
particles suggest that he could have
gotten tempted by that sweet sexy
dark dimension magic from dormammu and i
hear that once you go black
you know you know just kidding my ex
left me
quite quickly and you already know that
i cannot legally make this breakdown
without mentioning the man
the myth mr steal your motherboard
himself
zola and what's hilarious about this is
that this isn't even his first time with
a computer animated face
and this zola is 100 definitely from
captain carter's timeline for sure
because
this is when he was alive anyways moving
on
i am the watcher i observe all that
transpires here we get this
really interesting shot of this hooded
figure in a strange world and this
is of course janet van dyne inside of
the quantum realm but
it looks like a zombie janet instead of
the beautiful unzombified
michelle pfeiffer i mean i'm not even
sure how a zombie janet gets the quantum
realm on her own but this could be a
scenario where the zombie outbreak
starts with the janet van dyne after she
is saved by hank like he picks her up
and he's like
oh you look kind of different but hey
it's my wife
so only matrimony and then she bites
them it's like hooray for zombie
matrimony
i mean there are a lot of weird
creatures within the quantum realm so
maybe one of them is some type of
zombie virus and then later we have our
boy peter parker
shooting webs at an off-screen target a
target implied to be
scarlet witch herself mostly because
this shot of scarlet witch later on
shows her repulsing away okoye spear but
also
peter parker's webs so this could be our
very first look at avengers from another
universe trying to contain our wanda
while she goes proper multiverse mad but
then towards the end of the trailer we
get a ton of quick flashes of moments
from the series
but i do not cannot will not interfere
i guess i have to freestyle then
hey that stood out to me most were this
shot of pepper potts and shuri playing
swan
fbi open up
an older version of ego the living
planet using his powers on earth
implying that he did return
scott lang without a freaking body
natasha on a bike dodging blaster fire
from ultron bots in a post-apocalyptic
age of ultron
type world i'm assuming and this very
same natasha throwing red guardian
shield and since it's only been a few
weeks since the last time we saw vision
die
have another one with vision attempting
to pluck out the mind stone
from his own head marvel kevin please
we would all be very domo origato if you
would just give mr roboto
a goddamn break please what if
you didn't what if marvel my heart can't
take it anymore
and then finally we get this very
humorous moment of t'challa voiced by
the late
king chadwick himself a ravager never
flies
solo i said
never flies solo
is that some kind of catchphrase
you had me worried for a second walking
out of the morocc temple with korath the
pursuer on his back which suggests to me
that t'challa's years as a ravager did
not remove
an ounce of this man's innate compassion
because much like he spared zemo's life
in civil war he decided to spare koraf's
life because that's just who he is so
r.i.p chadwick boseman we miss you very
much
and you have inspired all of us to be
better people very much looking forward
to seeing your final performance in
what if but yeah that is it for my
breakdown of marvel's new
what if trailer what scenario are you
most excited for is it what if
killmonger saved tony stark or what if
marvel zombies took over the mcu
let us know below my nerd babies but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter or instagram
if you want to see me post some weird
[ __ ] but most importantly you can follow
new rockstars wherever we are in the
internet especially on youtube and when
you do
make sure that you hit the notification
bell so that you can get notifications
whenever we upload some dope [ __ ] which
is like 24 7. of course be sure to hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can get
dope shirts like this
loki limited edition the latest
obsession shirt but anyways i love you
guys so much be safe be well and i will
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you